all right narcissists and social media
by Joey B Tunes let's get surgical well
folks Summer's right around the corner
and the insta floozies are out in full
force documenting the results of their
parents failures here's one leaving
their snail Trail all over the local
running track somebody actually spoke up
for once listen to this just in the most
public
maybe elsewhere no way to hear this
response you know what there's no reason
for you guys to tell me what to do
because I am actually a content creator
this is how I make money okay and um I
have like so many followers on Instagram
you guys really don't want to like okay
mess with me yeah imagine threatening an
adult with pervert to watch you on the
internet I have like so many followers
on Instagram you guys really don't want
to like okay mess with me I mean how did
we go from don't mess with me or my
brother will kick your ass to don't mess
with me I entertain random perverts
online who will defend my honor I mean
what kind of culture is this this lady
is just it honestly is sad to see a girl
that thinks like that you know you
couldn't pick a better time than when
the local middle school kids are playing
football to go and do this there's no
time to be in a public park acting like
that but especially during the day when
there could be Children and Families
there yeah yeah so weird you're a skank
I don't like you guys just coming over
here and like telling me to like leave I
agree I don't like it either I love
attention she couldn't possibly want
attention more oh my God me and my
friends used to make sure shot videos so
we go on top of a garage and we throw a
football off of it into the basketball
hoop but we wouldn't do it if there was
kids and people around you'd have to
we'd wait you know what I mean oh we
gotta show the trick shot video that
when the time when it wasn't really a
trick shot the one where you know which
one I'm talking about should I just pull
it up real quick so when Sonny was
little he used to make all these fun
videos yeah pull it up and uh one time
he had this one where he
decided he was in the he was in the gym
in our local neighborhood and he decided
to hit a basketball with a baseball
found it okay
oh yeah he [ __ ] knocked himself out
so wait we're gonna play it again and
this time just focus on his head
[Applause]
all right let's get back to this video
wish they could have tarred and
feathered you instead but it's illegal I
think there's a better spot to do this
yeah like on the corner of ninth and
Broadway around 2 A.M monetize the
street corner you'll get a lot of new
followers there well actually we're not
even supposed to have anybody that's not
that is not there in a school program
here on the field especially I actually
used to come to this school yeah I used
to go to a school too maybe I'll show up
to the school cafeteria on a speedo and
have a photo shoot and the lunch lady's
tub of macaroni and cheese yeah and when
she asked me to leave I'll just be like
you and say I used to come to this
school I actually used to come to this
school and then I'll proceed to wonder
why that doesn't matter as she beats me
over the head with a soup spoon I have
got all ready for the day came ready to
take my photos this is a I'm a content
creator this is what I do for a living
so got it I mean do you people even know
what you're saying and how it adds
nothing to the rationalization of what
you're doing it kind of sucks it doesn't
to putting me in this position and make
me feel really uncomfortable yeah you
know who else would be really
uncomfortable right now your father if
he's stuck around sorry if I offended
you guys talk about being uncomfortable
you don't even look comfortable in your
own skin look at you you're just
constantly touching yourself fixing your
clothes I mean these people are trying
to have a conversation with you and you
can't even stop thinking about your
looks during it I mean this is manic
behavior here we're just we tried to
suggest something that we think is good
for you okay okay well I'm just gonna
leave now look at her she's mad now
thank you for nothing though
while I get dressed
I'm sure the [ __ ] the players are
complaining I know but everyone
yeah how dare people uphold standards in
their Community people in their common
decency the only people are more like me
and film themselves spreading Eagle at
their old high school maybe then this
place would feel more like a community
good Lord look if you're upset at people
for being upset with you for your lack
of common decency then you obviously
have none and if you have none don't be
surprised when people that do tell you
to get the [ __ ] out you don't have to
have decency you're allowed to be a
degenerate but why don't you make your
life easier and just find other people
who have no class or dignity to parade
around in front of the Walmart parking
lot's a good start I'm sure the guy who
lives in a station wagon with trash all
around his car won't mind start there
and then work your way towards the
dumpster there's a whole new breed of
Travelers that hang around back there
that'll love some entertainment all I'm
saying is you got options leave the
community parks and schools alone if
you've been following me on patreon I've
been going through the entire season of
hype house talk about the generates this
is an entire room full of them who live
together
I don't know nothing about this I've
been putting this last episode off for a
while now I just can't keep my food down
but if you want to watch me torture
myself I'm doing episode four today Link
in the description wish me luck I don't
want to watch that I just I just don't
want to even know that hot what hype
house is no yeah no they offered my
friends a spot in the
oh it's just too cringy I know I didn't
do it
[Music]
[Music]